السلاحف البحريه واحده من اكثر الحيوانات
البحريه عرضه للمخاطر هنا في البرازيل قصه
نجاح وقعت على احد شواطئ البلاد في حمايه
السلاحف من خطر الانقراض والهلاك بسبب صيد
الجائر والتلوث البيئي
[موسيقى]
اينشتانكي
مشروع ضخم لحمايه السلاحف يسمى تمر وهو
خطه واسعه لانقاذ السلاحف البحريه عن طريق
23 مركزا منتشرا على طول الساحل يعمل
المشروع على تدقيق عامه الناس وتجميع
الحيوانات المريضه او المصابه
جاليريلا واحده من القائمين على هذا
المشروع تقوم بدوريات ليليه على الشاطئ
لتقفي الاثارات تلك السلاحف
[موسيقى]
يلا
واحده من اكثر الانواع انتشارا على شواطئ
البرازيل يبلغ طولها اكثر من متر ويتخطى
وزنها المئتين كلغ
سلاحف كوان عرضه كغيرها للانقراض لوقوعها
ضحيه في شباك الصيادين او تعرضها للاختناق
بواسطه الاكياس البلاستيكيه التي تلوث
المياه هنا
مهما
تعبان
على الرغم من اتخاذ اجراءات صارمه هنا ضد
الصيادين المحليين الذين يصطادون السلاحف
الا انه تمت الاستعانه بهم واعاده توظيفهم
لمساعده علماء الاحياء
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
مشاريع وتمر التي توظف اكثر من الف شخص
وتستقطب نحو 600 الف زائر سنويا نجحت على
مدار 30 سنه من توفير الحمايه لهذه
الحيوانات الضعيفه
والمساهمات لابقاء العديد منها على قيد
الحياه وحمايتها من خطر الفناء والانقراض
[موسيقى]